[Music]
in this week's news episode we cover
many topics particularly worth
mentioning is the departure of Henry
Cavill from The Witcher series but also
a dual leadership at the renamed DC
Studios will have a strong impact on the
years to come additionally we talk about
Venom 3 Avatar 2 Wonder Man and the last
of us and last but not least you get to
find out what Disney's new Hercules
movie has to do with Tick Tock we hope
you enjoy our new video
the expectations for the upcoming the
last of a series are high on the one
hand they have to succeed in
transforming one of the best video games
of the last PlayStation generation into
a live action series on the other hand
the already critical fan base also needs
to be satisfied whereas skepticism was
high particularly at the beginning of
the series production many fans are now
looking forward to the HBO series as a
result of having seen the first images
and the first trailer until now we only
knew approximately when the last of us
would hit the domestic screens for the
first time namely at the beginning of
2023 the responsible parties kept quiet
about an exact release date which is why
it is all the more surprising that HBO
accidentally leaked the series premiere
date themselves on the corresponding HBO
store Page you are able to see for a few
hours that January 15 2023 was selected
as the official release date before the
mistake was noticed by HBO it was
already circulating in the relevant
Forums on the web and was thus quickly
known to the general public shortly
after the mishap became known the
official the last of us Twitter account
followed up and officially shared a
poster for the series as well as a
confirmation of the previously published
date we're excited for more news and
look forward to the last of us being
released soon on January 15 2023.
no one was expecting this surprising
news as The Witcher star Henry Cavill
announced last Saturday he will quit the
highly popular series Around The Witcher
geralt Olivia after three seasons on
Twitter Facebook and Instagram the 39
year old shared his news with his fans
where he literally spoke of laying down
his Witcher Medallion and swords for
season 3. at the same time Cavill
announced that Liam Hemsworth will carry
on playing Geral which means that at
least the series itself will be kept
alive this week cabell's departure has
fueled speculation as to what his
motivations for leaving early might have
been it is obvious to assume that he
will now fully dedicate himself to his
return to the role of Superman in the
dceu as we've known since at least the
promotional stages of Black Adam Cabo is
coming back for a sequel to Man of Steel
and probably also for a Black Adam vs
Superman teased by Dwayne Johnson
however is this really the reason for
his early parting from The Witcher a
second plausible Theory focuses on
plot-related decisions that Cavill as a
big fan of the books is said to have
disagreed with in interviews for exam
Temple he has often spoke about how he
constantly advocated for the series
character geralt to be closer to the
novel character and if possible with no
creative deviations this request was
consistently disregarded making Henry
cavill's departure inevitable in the
opinion of many fans whether the quality
of the series will suffer from this
drastic cast change is not apparent yet
the majority of fans are still surprised
and upset about cavil's decision to
leave and do not yet want to imagine a
change of characters this will not be
easy for successor Liam Hemsworth who
will not only have to follow in the
footsteps of cavil but will also have to
win over a Discerning fan base Hemsworth
at least seems to be in High Spirits and
expresses his Joy about his new role on
Instagram the final episodes with Henry
Cavill will be released in the summer of
2023 after that it's not known when
production on season 4 will begin
with 507 million US dollars in box
office takings Venom Let There Be
Carnage was a total success in 2021 the
fact that a third part is in the works
has actually been clear since a
statement by lead actor Tom Hardy back
in 2018 then all doubts were removed
since the success of the second part
meanwhile those responsible behind the
scenes have not been sitting idle
deadline recently reported that the
director's position has already been
filled Kelly Marcel who already
contributed to the scripts of the two
predecessors is now taking over as
director for the first time in her
career it's certainly a bold move to put
an inexperienced director in charge of
Venom 3. on the other hand however she
is very familiar with the franchise
thanks to her work as a writer Marcel
will be working on the movie in a dual
role as both the director and
screenwriter so she Bears a lot of
responsibility currently there is no
information about the storyline or the
cast but we are really excited about the
further developments in the Sony
Spider-Man universe
the promotional campaign is well
underway and indeed it won't be long
before Avatar in the way of water hits
theaters the interval between part 1 and
part 2 is an impressive 13 years
nevertheless many movie fans are excited
to see how good the late sequel is going
to be after so many years in the making
the big question is will James Cameron
succeed in thrilling audiences to such
an extent that the three additional plan
sequels will also create anticipation
among the public or will the huge
project flop and bring Cameron's life
work to an untimely end at least fans
who have a soft spot for long movies
will get their money's worth as deadline
Than The Hollywood Reporter point out
Avatar the way of water will break the
three hour mark when it comes to the
runtime the movie is said to be at least
190 minutes in length probably even
longer that Cameron cannot convince
everyone what the lengthy running time
is something he has already confirmed in
several interviews but he isn't too
concerned about the duration of the film
as people sometimes also watch several
episodes of a series at a time and that
can certainly add up to more than three
hours whether Avatar the way of water
will also manage to fill the length with
exciting content however will only
become apparent with its release on
December 16 2022.
there has been a lot of action in the DC
Universe lately after a whole bunch of
new projects were recently presented
there is now even more news about the
creative reorientation of the company
the studio DC films which is mainly
responsible for the dceu has been
renamed DC Studios and has been given a
new management as of November 1st this
new management is in the hands of the
two equally responsible Partners Peter
Safran and James Gunn whereas saffron is
the movie producer of films such as
Aquaman and the lost kingdom and Shazam
Fury of the Gods James Gunn creator of
The Suicide Squad and Guardians of the
Galaxy probably requires no further
introduction both now supervise any film
or series project associated with DC
brand Bay are thus comparable to Kevin
feige who has been the creative
Mastermind in charge of the MCU at
competitor Marvel for years in the
future together they are to ensure that
the dceu as a whole becomes more
appealing again and is able to hold its
own against the powerful competitors
even though both CEOs have equal rights
Safran who studied law will be more
involved in the commercial side of
things while Gunn with his artistic
training in years of experience as a
director will keep a closer eye on the
creative details Henry Cavill showed
himself pleased about the new management
team at DC as well he himself has not
yet met the 56 year old gun but is
looking forward to long talks with The
Talented filmmaker for his returning
part as Superman Cabell also has some
ideas that he would like to discuss with
Gunn he says the Man of Steel is not
only a fantastic superhero but also one
with a big heart who always seems to
give more than he takes for Cabell
Superman represents nothing less than
the best in people and so he's looking
forward to movies with a more cheerful
Superman as the actor has emphasized in
the past we are certainly eager to see
how the next DC movies will be received
by audiences and look forward to more
news from the two CEOs what are your
thoughts on the creative revamp of the
DC Universe do you think James Gunn and
Peter Safran are up to the task or do
you not believe the DCU has a chance to
catch up with Marvel in terms of Pop
popularity let us know your views in the
comments
Yaya Abdul Mateen II is known to many as
the villain Black Manta in Aquaman or as
the main character in the new action
thriller film ambulance now the 36 year
old is facing new acting challenges that
may soon await him in the MCU based on
recent reports from Hollywood according
to these sources Abdul Mateen is to play
the main character in The planned Wonder
Man series and will thus stand on the
side of the good guys this time in a
superhero Blockbuster Wonder Man was
first introduced to the Marvel Comics
Universe back in 1964 in The Avengers
number 9 where he was even originally
designed to be the antagonist of the
Avengers though he later turned into a
superhero after all hence there is
already a bit of a connection to the MCU
and it will be interesting to see how
Wonder Man will eventually be introduced
into the film in series Universe Destin
Daniel [ __ ] who previously directed
Shang Chi and the legend of the ten
rings and who is also the director of
Avengers the Kang Dynasty will be the
producer the script was written by
Andrew guest who was involved in the
production of the Hawkeye series for
example in addition to Yaya Abdul Mateen
II in the lead role we can also look
forward to a comeback of Ben Kingsley as
Trevor Slattery a precise release date
for Wonderman is currently not known but
we'll make sure to keep you posted
after The Lion King Pinocchio and
Aladdin the wave of Disney remakes
continues the biggest criticism is that
the quality of the live-action movies
can vary greatly with Pinocchio in
particular recently receiving a lot of
criticism among the upcoming projects is
a Hercules movie from Avengers endgame
creators Anthony and Joe Russo like many
of its predecessors it will be produced
in a live-action format and the movie
will be held by Aladdin director guy
Richie a statement by producer Joe Russo
recently caused a stir when he talked
about the style of the film in an
interview with variety he stated that
the film is to be made in the style of a
musical and that the overall approach is
to be more experimental what is
particularly noteworthy is that Russo is
focusing more on the new generation and
no longer on the children of the 90s who
grew up with the original film as such
the movie will be geared toward the
spirit of today's times with a focus on
viewers who are used to Tick-Tock
content what exactly that means for the
plot of Hercules is currently the
subject of speculation however it's a
fact that with this statement Russo
hasn't necessarily created positive
publicity nevertheless it will be
interesting to see how the finished film
will be received by the target audience
unfortunately there is no release date
for the live action adaptation yet
that was the news for this week still
want to know more then check out our
latest original episode where we
explored the prequel to The Hunger Games
with the ballad of songbirds and snakes
and while you're here why not give this
video a highly appreciated thumbs up
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time
thank you laughs
[Music]